donc alors aujourd'hui vous avez fait
cinq albums cinq films et votre dernier
film cette seconde est complètement al
oula cette histoire de don quichotte là
c'est horrible cette histoire non
c'était dur on était face au moment où
ça s'est passé puisque jean rochefort se
faire opérer mais qui maintient pour lui
c'est un film s'appelle l'homme qui a
tué dans le fichage de terry gilliam qui
est un grand réalisateur donc avec vous
avec johnny depp jean rochefort dans le
rôle de effectivement de don quichotte
le deuxième jour le plateau est inondé
le quatrième jour guillian découvre que
le paysage a changé de couleur etc il
est pur accord et qu'il faut tout
refaire
le cinquième jour c'est horrible où
l'assistant découvre que rochefort peut
pas tourner ils se disputent il tente
quand même il faut trois personnes pour
le faire descendre de cheval et le
sixième jour il est évacué sur sur paris
et le tournage est interrompu et vous
après votre dos truc à faire vous avez
votre tournée et j'imagine que johnny
depp il a aussi des engagements et le
projet est abandonné il aura jamais on
verra jamais ce film ça vous touche
moins qu'avant ce genre de trucs depuis
que vous êtes mère de famille je vais
appeler votre album glisse dont
plusieurs féliciter vous dit finalement
on pouvait toujours dit que j'aimais pas
beaucoup qu'on parle de votre vie privée
dans la presse la télévision et là dans
cet album bliss au parler que de ça
c'est un peu contradictoire non d'une
certaine façon oui peut-être mais je ne
raconte pas de détails je parle de
sujets universels qui qui qui concerne
enfin une grande partie des femmes ouais
c'est dans le général il n'ya pas il n'y
a pas de détail a pas de 2 c'est pas un
journal intime et puis c'était la
première fois que j'écrivais des
chansons j'avais envie de parler des des
gens et des choses que j'aime le plus
elle est loin l'époque de savin
si une chanson de florent pagny à
l'époque vous étiez ensemble vous avez
tellement de problèmes avec les
paparazzi qui avait fait cette chanson a
pas les paparazzis oui la presse qui est
bi et trans parmi gelé souffert de ça à
l'époque
mais à l'époque
vous croyez que ce n'est pas du tout
cette pression de la presse votre couple
aurait pu continuer annonce n 16